Lockangebote ohne Ende,
aber keiner kommt.
So sieht‘s in vielen deutschen Einkaufszonen
aus, auch wenn’s nicht so kalt ist.
Minus zehn Grad in Günzburg,
einer kleinen bayrischen Stadt.
Da traut sich nur raus, wer dringend
etwas braucht.
Grüß Gott!
Hallo, ich brauche einen Skihelm.
Skihelm? Dann gehen Sie doch am
besten mit mir nach hinten,
da zeig‘ ich Ihnen, was wir dahaben.
Okay.
Schon nächste Woche soll’s
für mich losgehen.
...Helm,  können'S  gerne
mal aufprobieren.
Ich will in den Skiurlaub und das
wird bestimmt teuer.
Menga JV, Alpina ...
Ich wollt‘ noch mal ganz schnell gucken,
wie viel das möglicherweise bei
der Konkurrenz kostet.
Was kostet der denn hier,
wenn ich fragen darf?
Bei uns kostet der Helm im Moment
129 im Sonderpreis.
129.
129 Euro.
119 ... 106 ...
Müssen Sie halt jetzt ... Wenn Sie
wirklich im Internet nachschauen,
haben Sie halt nirgendwo die Gewähr,
dass er Ihnen von der Größe her passt.
Hier haben Sie den in der Größe,
den [die] Sie genau brauchen,
und Sie bekommen ihn sogar
mit Beratung.
Ja, aber wenn ich das online bestelle,
dann kann ich‘s natürlich auch
mir liefern lassen
und wieder zurückschicken, wenn‘s
mir nicht gefällt.
Ist überhaupt gar kein Problem, das
können Sie bei uns genauso.
Gehen Sie auf unsere Webseite,
„wir-in-günzburg.de“,
und dann kriegen Sie den Helm,
wenn Sie ihn heute bis 16 Uhr 30 bestellen,
sogar noch heute geliefert.
„wir-in-günzburg.de“ gibt es seit
einem halben Jahr.
50 Händler, tausende Angebote.
Nikola Tesch hat die Seite aufgebaut.
Ist das Günzburgs Antwort
auf Amazon?
Ganz ehrlich, gegen Amazon
hat keiner ‘ne Chance.
Auch wir als Günzburger Unternehmen
jetzt nicht in diesem Sinne,
sondern diese Website ist wirklich
einfach dazu da,
sich online zu präsentieren.
Die Kunden kommen sowohl aus
ganz Deutschland
als auch aus Günzburg.
Wir haben quasi Hälfte Günzburger,
Hälfte deutschlandweit Bestellungen.
Aber kann das den Umsatzrückgang
durch Bestellungen
bei zum Beispiel Amazon stoppen?
Im Buchladen, wo auch Schulbedarf,
wie Ranzen, angeboten wird,
erfahre ich einen weiteren Trick
der Kunden.
Wenn man den Barcode fotografiert,
was passiert dann, Herr Hutter?
Ja, dann ist es so, dass Sie heutzutage...
müssen Sie ‘ne Software haben,
wo automatisch dann hier das Produkt
im Internet angezeigt wird ...
Es gibt also Kunden, die
in den Laden kommen,
sich die Produkte anschauen und dann,
wenn ihnen das Produkt gefällt,
fotografieren.
Das ist natürlich ganz schön dreist,
also, ich meine ...
Ja, sicher, man nennt das manchmal
auch Beratungsklau.
Aber das ist halt heute so.
Ich hab‘ hier in Günzburg auch mal ‘ne
Geschäftskollegin getroffen,
die mir gesagt hat, ‘ne Frau hat zehn
Hosen anprobiert,
und am Schluss hat sie‘s Foto gemacht
und hat gesagt:
„Und die bestell‘ ich jetzt im Internet.“
Hermann Hutter ist deshalb schon seit
Jahren selbst im Internet aktiv.
Er hat ein eigenes Lager mit
hunderttausenden Artikeln.
„Die Leute gehen immer seltener in
die Stadt“, sagt er. Und das hat Folgen.
Wenn man nicht in der Stadt ist,
kann man keine Impulskäufe machen.
70 Prozent aller Käufe sind Impulskäufe,
und damit quasi ...
Wenn ich nicht den Mantel kaufe, nicht
in die Stadt fahre,
habe ich auch nicht die Chance,
ein Buch oder einen Stift zu kaufen.
Auf der anderen Seite sind die Kunden,
dank Internet,
so gut informiert wie noch nie,
wenn sie in den Laden kommen.
Und davon profitieren die Händler.
Auch in diesem Weinladen fragen
Kunden gezielt nach Produkten,
probieren den Wein und lassen ihn
sich dann zuschicken.
Ich hab‘ nur italienische Weine,
davon aber 800 verschiedene
aus allen Regionen Italiens
von Nord nach Süd,
über die Inseln ...
Sie finden bei mir Rotweine, Weißweine,
Roséweine und auch Schaumweine.'
Ne Auswahl, wie man sie normalerweise
nur in großen Städten findet,
biete ich hier in Günzburg, in einer
relativ kleinen Stadt.
Das geht aber nur, weil ich eben die
Kombination betreibe zwischen
stationären[m] Handel und
Online-Handel.
Ohne den Online-Handel im Hintergrund
könnte ich kein so großes Sortiment
vorhalten
und könnte auch die günstigen Preise
nicht anbieten.
Was zahle ich denn dafür?
9 Euro 80.
Und wenn ich das jetzt in Berlin
bestellen würde
– ich wohne ja in Berlin –, wie viel würde
ich dann dafür bezahlen?
Überhaupt kein Problem. Sie zahlen
da auch 9,80 Euro dafür,
Sie bestellen es über die Plattform
„wir-in-günzburg“.
Dort verschicken wir die Weine
versandkostenfrei innerhalb Deutschlands.
Zum Wohl!
Dank Internet haben die Läden jetzt
eine echte Überlebenschance.